le matériel chirurgical oublier dans un
patient avant que celui-ci ne soit
refermé en classique les compresses
oubliées dans le ventre et ce qui est
arrivé en 2011 à un patient de 72 ans
opéré dans les hautes scènes pour ce
qu'il pensait être une tumeur de plus de
16 cm la tumeur s'est avérée en réalité
une compresse laissez-la 11 ans plus tôt
par un chirurgien parfois il s'agit même
d'instruments la même année à Lyon une
patiente a dû être réopérée pour lui
retirer une pince oubliée dans son
abdomen 7 mois plus tôt et qui
commençait à ressortir toute seule par
son nombril mais la palme revient à un
gynécologue jordanien en 2015 qui après
avoir pratiqué une césarienne sur une de
ses patientes ne retrouvez plus son
téléphone portable et pour cause
quand on regarde d'un peu plus près les
causes de ce genre d'accident on
retrouve parfois une accumulation
d'erreurs individuelle mais le plus
souvent un non respect des procédures à
un moment ou à un autre pour gagner du
temps par exemple c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles la course à la
rentabilité dans le domaine de la santé
c'est pas une bonne